blue bloods on cbs has a who's who of
talent in the cast not the least of
which is tv legend tom selleck as a
family patriarch frank reagan to one
generation of viewers select may be best
known for his role on magnum pi but his
presence on blue bloods means he's a
rare actor with multiple iconic
television roles to his name many actors
are lucky enough to get just one but
then again selik isn't like most actors
and you can tell that's the case by the
way his co-stars talk about him selik
may have years of acting experience
under his belt far more than any other
performer on blue bloods but donny
wahlberg who plays danny reagan on the
police procedural more than holds his
own against him the two have had ample
scenes together over the years so
suffice to say the two actors have had
numerous opportunities to get to know
each other as expected wahlberg has
nothing but kind things to say about his
coaster considering tom selleck has
decades of experience in the industry it
should come as no surprise to hear that
he's a delight to work with in an
interview with outsider donnie wahlberg
lets it be known that he adores working
alongside the veteran actor he said tom
celek is a leader himself he is a very
experienced very smart guy very
dedicated much like myself there are
times when we both see the hidden game
and we both want the same thing but we
have very different ideas on how to do
it it's a great sensation for an actor
to go up against someone who challenges
them it prevents one from getting
complacent and helps them strive to
deliver another stellar performance
warburg goes on to describe how it's
almost like a dance between the two
saying knowing when to step up knowing
that this is the time tom could really
use my input or knowing when to step
back and knowing this is the time i
gotta trust tom it is very truthful
offscreen as it is on screen for danny
and frank part of the reason why selick
and wolberg get along so well is because
wolberg sees a lot of his own father in
selik's character in a 2013 interview
with the huffington post wahlberg spoke
about what drew him to blue bloods in
the first place as one of nine children
wolberg could relate to his character
dany as one of a group of siblings who
often squabble but always come together
in the end wahlberg said blue bloods is
a throwback show because they don't make
shows that focus on families like this
anymore everything's focused on the
unusual family when i read the pilot the
family dinner scene attracted me most i
felt the heat of my dad staring down at
me and my sister while we're arguing and
that same heat's there with tom selleck
and bridget moynihan and it's not just
the arguments that reminds warburg of
his own family it's the lighter moments
too he said just like we teased tom on
screen that's directly from my childhood
with my dad he was a very tough guy and
we loved trying to break through that
hard exterior and make him laugh
wahlberg and selik's relationship has
deepened in the 11 years since
bluebloods first went on the air in a
recent interview with entertainment
tonight which he gave shortly after the
death of his mother omar wahlberg talked
about his bond with selik i call him dad
now he calls me sun i mean that's how we
talk to each other
with a show like blue bloods it only
works if the actors playing a family can
believably come off that way luckily for
wahlberg and selik it doesn't sound like
they have to fake the father-son dynamic
too much and that's one of the many
reasons why blue bloods has connected so
well with fans
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]